we gotta get you into world war one
we gotta get you more into world war one
because
i think that's a rabbit hole which i
know you're a dan carlin fan
so blueprint for armageddon yeah
guaranteed
but but there's fewer evil people there
yes but well but that's what actually
there's a banality of that evil of the
kaiser
and of the uh austro-hungarians
and of see i like world war one more
because it was unresolved it's one of
those periods i was talking to you about
about like sometimes you're called and
you
fail like that's what happened i mean 50
million people were killed
in the most horrific way like people
literally drowned in the mud like
like an entire generation one stat i
love is that
you know britain didn't need a draft
till 1916.
like they went two years of throwing
people into barbed wire
voluntarily yeah and because people love
their country and they love the king
and they thought they were going against
the kaiser it's just like
that conflict to me i just can't read
enough about it
also just like births russian revolution
you know
yeah i mean hitler you can't talk about
world war ii without world war one right
right
and i'm obsessed with the conflict i've
read way too many books about it
for this reason is it's unresolved and
like the the roots of so much of even
our current problems
are happening in versailles right like
vietnam is
because of the treaty of versailles um
many ways the middle eastern problems
and the division of the states there
the treaty of versailles in terms of the
penalties against
germany but also the uh fallout from
those wars on the french
and the german popular the french and
the british populations and their
reluctance
for war in 1939 or 1938
when when neville chamberlain goes right
like that's one of the things people
don't understand is the actual appetite
of the british public
at that time they didn't want to go to
war only churchill he was the only one
in the
you know in the gathering storm right
like being like hey this is really bad
and all of that and then even in the
united states our streak of isolationism
which
swept i mean things were because of that
conflict
we were convinced as a country that we
wanted
nothing to do with europe and its
problems and in many ways that
contributed to the proliferation of
hitler and more so like
i'm obsessed with world war one for this
reason which is that it's just like the
root
oh it's like the culmination of the
monarchies then the fall
and then just all the [ __ ] spills out so
from there for like a hundred years
so world war one is like the most
important shift in human history world
war ii is like a consequence of that
yeah it's it's so i have a degree in
security studies from georgetown and one
of the thing is that we would focus a
lot on that is like war
and but also like the complexity around
war
and it's funny we never spent that much
time on world war ii
because it was actually quite of a clean
war it's a very atypical war
as in the war object which we learned
from world war one
is we must inflict suffering on the
german people
and invade the borders of germany and
destroy hitler
like the center of gravity is the nazi
regime and hitler
so it had a very basic begin and end
begin liberate france invade germany
destroy hitler reoccupy rebuild
world war one what are you fighting for
like
are you i mean and nobody even knew you
can go the german general staff they
were like
even in 1917 they're like the war was
worth it because now we have luxembourg
i'm like really like you killed two
million of your citizens for [ __ ]
luxembourg
and like half of belgium which is now
like a pond yeah and same thing
the french are like well the french more
so they're defending their borders but
like
what are the british fighting for why
did hundreds of thousands of british
people die
in order to preserve the balance of
power in europe and prevent the kaiser
from having a port on the english
channel
like really that's why these that's more
what wars are is they become these like
atypical they become these
protracted conflicts with a necessary
diplomatic
resolution it's not clean it's
very dirty it usually leads in the
outbreak of another war and another war
and another war in a slow burn of ethnic
conflict
which bubbles up so that's why i look at
that one
even because it's it's more typical of
warfare yeah how it works
exactly yeah it's it's kind of
interesting you're making me realize
uh that uh world war ii is one of the
rare
wars where you can make a strong case
for it's a fight of good versus
war theory obviously like yeah they're
literally slaughtering jews like
you and there's one person doing it i
mean there's one person at the core
there's
it's uh yeah that's fascinating and it's
short and there's a clear aggression
you